la majorité de la droite et du centre du
Sénat et Gérard Larcher avec la majorité
présidentielle veulent un vote on l'a
dit est-ce que c'est quand même pas plus
courageux politiquement de voter ce
texte que de refuser de le voter
est-ce que les parlementaires ne sont
pas là pour voter des textes pour dire
clairement la question n'est pas la
aujourd'hui la question qui est posée on
inverse un peu les élus pour voter des
textes et pour vous prononcer
des pratiques anti-démocratiques on
n'est pas élus pour que à dire reprise
on utilise à l'Assemblée un 47,3 pour
faire passer un budget parce que le
gouvernement n'a pas de majorité on
n'est pas élu pour accepter que le
gouvernement utilise un projet de loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale
rectificative qui lui permet de passer
son vote qui lui permet de raccourcir
les débats qui lui permet de faire à peu
près ce qu'il veut alors en plus avec
soit l'article 38 au Sénat soit le 49-3
à l'Assemblée enfin tout ça n'est tout
ça enfin je veux dire ça montre bien que
on est arrivé je crois dans ce pays
parce qu'il y a plein d'autres pays où
il y a pas assez de possibilités de
comme ça de contraindre le Parlement à
accepter ce qu'il n'accepte pas on est
arrivé à une vraie crise dont seulement
politique mais une crise de régime tout
ça
on est une crise politique ça c'est
clair la preuve c'est que j'ai cru
comprendre que Madame borne estime
qu'elle est même pas sûr d'avoir une
agence ils m'ont dit même dans une crise
d'origine c'est plus supportable que
tout renvoie à une seule personne au
présent de la République et d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que moi je crois que le
cœur du problème les syndicats l'ont
l'Inter syndical a bien la bien ciblée
c'est Emmanuel Macron c'est lui
aujourd'hui qui doit faire en sorte et
je lui ai fait un appel solennel ce
matin il doit retirer ses poids parce
que c'est lui qui l'a voulu à tout prix
c'est lui qui l'a voulu par le plfsr et
c'est lui qui l'a voulu contre tout un
pays on gouverne pas contre tout un pays
il est en train de mettre ce pays et en
tension c'est à lui qu'il revient de
sortir de la crise et donc il a une
possibilité pour ça enfin il sort de son
piédestal il reçoit les syndicats et
franchement quand vous avez plus de 60%
des Français qui sont d'accord avec la
grève qui sont d'accord avec ce que vous
appelez le blocage du pays et bien
on réfléchit deux secondes on arrête de
mettre ce pays en tension cette
cinquième république elle est à bout de
souffle et là je crois que c'est en
transe c'est ce qui est en train de
montrer Emmanuel Macron par une vision
très hyper présidentielle du régime mais
en plus en disant que non il va pas
recevoir les syndicats en conseil que
c'est très forme ça vient de lui
[Musique]